you know the challenges with crisis or
anything bad that happens to other
people is we never think it'll happen to
us for instance your marriage is good
and you see somebody else going through
divorce you're like oh my gosh okay I'm
going through the divorce but my
marriage is good you know your health is
good but someone else you said cancer
but it's not me it'll never happen to me
in my family but somebody else had
cancer oh look at the guys business man
they're going through a bad time but
we're going through good times it'll
never happen to us or you know country
oh my gosh look at the crisis that
country is experiencing but it'll never
happen to us because we're rich and
powerful never to us until it's too late
in boom it happens to you this happens
all the time listen if you turn on your
phone social media news TV whatever you
turn on Venezuela is gonna be mentioned
by somebody it is a travesty on what's
going on in Venezuela it is also very
sensitive so I'm gonna give two
different perspectives in today's video
you know if you look at what's going on
in Venezuela the average Venezuelan they
say lost 24 pounds in 2017 nearly 5
million estimated have escaped and left
Venezuela to other countries Colombia
apparently took in a million 1 million
students are not going to school because
there's no teachers and they don't have
food kids are eating food like rotten
meat is what they're eating because
there is nothing to buy minimum wage has
gone from 350 to $7 a month a cup of
coffee they used to cost 450 bolivars to
buy cost two point five million bull of
us to buy today 5000 journalists
detained because they spoke up against
my judo you know just recently Richard
Branson put a big concert and calling me
a right across the border you know the
whole story about what's going on let's
try to free Venezuela 200 some thousand
people showed up to this concert same
exact day Maduro put a concert in Venice
all a few hundred people showed up
saying hands off of Venezuela then you
got Guido that is trying to help
Venezuelans the opposition to Maduro and
everyone's wonder what is really going
on sat today's episode I'm gonna share
with you ten things that you and I can
learn from what's taking place in
Venezuela and I'm gonna give you data
about oil reserves about Venezuela
that's gonna shock you
[Music]
the reason why I have this on one hand
this marker here is because there's one
data I have a written here when I tell
you'll be shell-shocked I told you
earlier when I write this down you're
gonna say there's no way this is
possible look before we get into my ten
points I have here I first want to lay
the groundwork for us to see some of the
numbers so we just see facts data what's
really taking place right so first thing
I want to pay attention to is oil
reserve or leaders around the world what
countries this number that says two
hundred sixty six thousand 455 this is
in millions barrels so if I put millions
that we need to add six more zero so go
figure this is they're the leading
country in the world with the most
barrels right so when you look at the
leading countries in the world with the
most barrels in reserves you look at us
at the bottom at 39,000 to thirty right
x million which means 39 billion right
you look at Libya forty eight you look
at Russia eighty you look at United Arab
Emirates ninety seven eight Kuwait 101
Iraq 142 Iran 158 Canada no one talks
about 169 Saudi Arabia which is what
everybody talks about they're the
biggest when anything about oil you
think about Saudi Arabia Sheik you think
about Prince these are the guys that
have all the oil right right it is the
Middle East right nope
number one in the world is Venezuela you
ready
three hundred thousand eight seventy
eight times a million barrels they are
number one u.s. is number ten so why is
it such a big mess how is it that a
country with that much oil is going
through a mess today what took place
there's two numbers we have to look at
one is oil prices the other one we have
to look at is inflation let's first look
at oil prices this is not just Venezuela
oil prices this is oil prices per barrel
right but why oil prices what does oil
cost per barrel and historically what
has it done and is there a trend or
something that we ought to pay attention
to between Chavez and Maduro because
when Chavez was president people were
happy the economy was apparently doing
good some people said wait a minute we
were getting a lot of free programs
I mean why is it that under Maduro is
not working it must be out of module
asfalt
right let's look at this year look oil
prices today a barrel in 2019 give or
take as of yesterday's pricing is 52
dollars and 87 cents today a barrel 2019
2018 was 6490 2017 was 1584 2016 4358
2015 48 72 2014 93 17 why is 2014 so
critical from 93 17 to 48 72 here's why
it's critical Maduro got elected in 2014
Chavez died in 2013 so when Maduro first
got elected when isola was still kind of
okayed had some problems but they were
kind of ok
why were they kind of okay because oil
prices were so high the moment oil
prices dropped more than 50% they can no
longer fund all the public programs
because 50% of Venezuela's GDP is what
pays for all the free public programs
that Chavez came up with years ago and
why could Chavez do it let's keep going
I watched this 2013 oil prices 97 98 94
o 594 79 60 199 72-66 5641 stay with me
here 31:26 2530 19 when Chavez got
elected oil prices 1935 per barrel
during his reign it went from 1935 to
$97 and they are the number one leaders
in the world in oil reserve so he could
give all these three programs away while
oil prices were going up which means
what Venezuela's economy is controlled
by oil prices per barrel they go up it
could work it goes down catastrophe all
over Venezuela so what happened when oil
prices kept going up more free program
how saying this let me give the land
away let me take the land from the rich
let's give it to the poor let's take
this away let's give that away let's
give everything away up you know taxes
maybe 71% let's give everything away to
everybody no incentives but when the oil
prices went down a whole different story
so now what does this mean when
inflation let's look at inflation watch
this from 2012 today
what
inflation look like look at 2012 the
world inflation in 2012 was 4.0 7% world
inflation 4.0 7% Venezuela 21% 2013
world 3.66 when it's well of 40 2014 3.2
- Venezuela 62 point well look what
happened in 2014 it's still 93 right but
watch what happens 2015 world inflation
2.75 Venezuela 127 21% 2016 2.75 world
inflation Venezuela 254 2017 3.2 percent
world inflation Venezuela two points
2006 16 2018 world is three point seven
eight Venice well over two point six
million the IMF predicts this year when
as well as inflation will crack 10
million there is inflation then there is
hyperinflation what Venezuela's going
through is hyperinflation let me explain
- a hyperinflation is based on what an
economist said if the economy increases
inflation 50 percent a month
consecutively eventually becomes
hyperinflation 50 percent a month this
is what it means that means what costs a
dollar today on January 1st 12 months
later on December 31st whatever costs a
dollar now costs $130 that's
hyperinflation except Minnesota has
hyperinflation on steroids let me give
you some comparisons with other
countries inflation Venezuela has the
worst inflation in the world right
number two is South Sudan at 117 percent
crisis but not at Venezuela's place I
was in Argentina a couple months ago
they have crisis but their inflation is
47.6% turkey is twenty four point five
two percent or guai 6.1 percent Mexico's
five point nine Russia's four point two
India's three point eight u.s. is two
point one Armenia is one point nine
percent and Israel is point two percent
I just used some of the countries this
is not ranking like the top three is
banana solar South Sudan Argentina the
rest of are some notable countries I
want you to be paying attention on
what's going on there right so your ten
things I think we can learn from what's
taking place in Venezuela it is a
absolute crisis what's taking place over
there but we all have to pay attention
to this because some time
these things can come back and affect
you number one number one thing if your
country solely relies on a natural
resource and that Natural Resources
pricing you don't control other factors
around the world can dictate what the
price of your oil is gonna be per barrel
one thing happens you're wiped out when
it goes from ninety 3.17 to 48 the next
year and 50% of all the social programs
because when a soul as a socialistic
nation 50% of the social programs are
funded by oil what are you doing that
takes place then you have to go in debt
this is why they want to borrowed money
110 billion dollars they owe because
they have to keep borrowing money to be
able to fund all these social programs
right there are some countries around
the world that solely rely on their
natural resource you've gotta find other
things to rely on except outside of just
that number two when there's no food
when there's no medicine the nicest
person in the world can commit crime if
that person has a kid let me say this
again economy is doing bad you are not
letting food in you are not letting
medicine come in you are burning trucks
that are coming through the border to
bring food and medicine and all the
money in the world can't buy a medicine
that doesn't exist it doesn't matter
what's taking place any parent will do
anything to put food in the belly of
their kids anyone is capable of crime
when the economy goes it's very
important to keep the economy going
because if you don't it effects
everybody crime goes to the roof number
three look you go to dinner your dad
pays the bill fine you go to dinner you
pay the bill for your dad fine you go to
dinner somebody pays your bill because
that person's a millionaire one time
fine
two times fine you don't work for them
this is a friend imagine a guy you party
with okay and you party with this guy
every time you go out with this guy
that's the partying I got the bill on
the house bar on me order your drinks
club on me bottle services table all on
me I got it guys oh my gosh he's so cool
he's so cool he's so cool there's two
problems going on there one the problem
is that guy who had now has 50 people
with his entourage I go to clubs the day
Bunny goes those 50 people disappear
like this he's buying friends your
funding friends right you know it's the
worst thing that's worse than this the
people that are partying with him who
are being
ah there bill you know what muscles
getting weaker the muscle of making
their own money if you can't pay your
own bill and you solely rely on somebody
else to pay your own bill eventually the
ability to pay your own bill goes away
your muscles become so weak that all of
a sudden when it's pulled it's a crisis
that's what was taking place in
Venezuela bills being paid bills being
paid bills being paid all of his sin
wipe it out wait a minute what happened
here I was relying on all this stuff you
were paying me for this stuff you were
giving me shelter you were give me this
what just took place and they don't know
how to make the money so what happens to
a country like Venezuela just like it
happened to other countries like I'm
from Iran the job creators those that
know how to make money who work very
hard they leave to other places Colombia
Bogota us all over the place because
they know they're gonna go find a place
to make money because they know how to
work hard they'll go to other places and
the economy takes a big hit
never ever rely on somebody to pay your
bills for the rest your life number four
one of the most manipulative words yes
to be very careful with elections about
to come out everybody's using this word
free college education my name is Bernie
free college free college free free
college how can we be the richest
country in the world and we don't offer
free college how can we be the richest
country in the world richest country in
the world three free free free free boom
just because America is rich doesn't
mean we have to give free programs away
to everybody just because then as well
as the number one in oil reserves
doesn't mean they have to give it away
to everybody everybody be very careful
with the word free especially when
politicians say every time you hear the
word free replace it with the real
f-word you know which one I'm talking
about the F uck every time you hear the
word free just think about they're
saying the other word every time every
time you hear and this program is gonna
be free F bomb and this program is gonna
be free cap bomb free F bomb F bomb that
mom if you replace it politics would
actually make more sense to you if you
replace the word free with the F bomb
number five
never give too much control to the
government listen even if the most noble
spiritual whatever church-going person
takes over and you say what a nice man
and he decides to change everything he
changes the constitution is what Chavez
did he creates his own house which is
what Chavez did he takes control of the
military the executive branch judicial
legislative everything he takes control
but what a nice guy like him because
he's giving me free programs never fall
for it never give the government too
much control he eliminated term limits
we need term limits why because certain
yours is enough like listen we got a
replace to get somebody else to balance
it out no matter what side it is
listen Obama gave birth to Trump but
Bush gave birth to Obama you know
Clinton gave birth to Bush this this
goes back and forth because we need to
balance each other it's almost like an
eagle's flying every four to eight years
he needs kind of go like this a little
bit to balance it out we need that some
of these countries no term limits
unlimited no no don't give too much
trust to the government don't ever do
that because then you lose your ability
to choose you lose your ability to vote
be very close attention none there's a
lot of people that followed back to me
you're not living in America just
remember this no matter how noble the
leader looks like at the top still don't
give a hundred percent trust to the
government very important for you to
remember that number six many American
politicians praise Venice all under mm
oh my gosh look at Venezuela Americans
are so afraid of socialism look how
great it's working in Venezuela look at
greatest working in Venezuela I like you
know Bernie was one of looking at
greatest working in Venice or Bernie's a
great example seems like a normal guy
seems like he wants to do the right
thing he seems like a good guy but his
philosophies don't work when he kept
saying socialism works in Venezuela he's
not telling you the whole story it
worked because oil prices went from 19
to 94 I mean that's like free money to a
country especially if you're a leader in
oil reserves but you're not hearing the
whole story and all you hear is the
average voter looks at and says wow I
guess he's right it is working in
Venezuela why not do it in America rich
people have too much money we should
take the money or redistribute and give
it to everybody else and that sounds
noble and you're gonna hear it again
look what happened AOC Alexander Ocasio
Cortes Amazon shouldn't come to New York
Amazon shouldn't come to New York it is
unfair what Amazon's going to be doing
to New York Amazon was bringing $150,000
your salary to 25,000 workers in New
York that is
good thing for new york new york was
gonna give amazon 3.2 billion dollars
and that's normal by the way a lot of
companies get a billion dollar payout
nike general a lot of companies get big
payouts because they're moving to mark
you to city but new york was gonna make
twenty billion dollars over the next
decade decade and a half but they said
no we don't want you to come because why
cuz she said because if they come dude
due to competition rent prices will go
up property value is gonna go up in new
york and the governor of new york is
saying what are you talking about we
have the most powerful inflation company
and once come to New York you are
protesting and then she's celebrating oh
yes Amazon didn't come to New York New
York used to be in a number on a city in
the world for the most fortune 500
company headquarters to be there it is
not going to be there for too long
because a lot of people gonna pay
attention to it so you can't put too
much of that trust into the socialistic
noble concept that oh my gosh it sounds
really good but it doesn't work next
number seven pay close attention to your
taxes I've been saying this for so many
years listen go study taxes taxes is so
boring one of the lines I've heard for
years is there's two guarantees in life
you're gonna die you're gonna be taxed
so if you're gonna die you got a study
death and if you're going to be taxed
you better study taxes because it's just
what's going to be taking place and when
it comes down to taxes that takes me to
point number eight is the power of
incentives a country whatever they
create as an incentive that's what
people go after meaning if Venezuela
says no incentive don't worry about it
we'll give you an income we'll give you
food we'll give you this we'll give you
a house and we'll give you all this
stuff don't worry about it we'll give it
to you incentive goes away if America
says we'll give you incentive if you
create jobs we'll give you all the
southern incentives and Americans do it
then people get advantage of it do you
know a lot of people say why isn't that
company paying as much taxes as this
other person why that is unfair so
immediately emotional you're like wow
that kind of makes sense that that
company they made this much money how
come they're not paying any taxes
because that company created 400,000
jobs in America okay let's take those
taxes away let's take those incentives
away but let's also take those 400,000
jobs or are you okay with that 400,000
jobs that is 60,000 all your salary how
much tax was being paid what is sales
taxes how many families was being fed
how many kids are going to school
many people have a place to live because
that company created 400,000 jobs pay
very close attention to incentives at a
company a company will say if you do XYZ
you get promoted a country says this is
our tax system we give you an incentive
and XYZ people create jobs it's all
about how you create incentives if the
incentives are proper innovation Gosai
if the incentives are not innovation
doesn't go hide number nine sometimes a
crisis wakes up a nation look one of the
reasons why I totally feel for the
people of Venezuela on what they're
going through this is because when you
have so much power with oil when you are
number one oil reserves everybody you're
like the you're like the beautiful girl
that every man wants to be with because
there's like oh my gosh she is so sexy
Venezuela you are so sexy because of all
the oil you got Thing Thing Thing Thing
Thing Thing Thing Thing Thing right okay
now watch I'm from Iran in Iran there's
a city called Abaddon any run this city
called Abaddon they found oil they
realize oh my gosh there's not just a
little bit of oil there's a lot of oil
in Abaddon and the person in Iran at
that time like I don't really know how
to handle this you case smell the
opportunity Britain they came and they
said oh listen we can help you
orchestrate it because we know how it is
to deal with this kind of stuff we're
the experts and Iran doesn't know how to
do it at that time they were just coming
up like okay what do we do maybe we
should give them an opportunity today
Kim and I said look we want to team up
with you let's start a company together
they called the company a POC
anglo-persian oil company you know what
it's called today by the way a POC BP
British Petroleum was once known as a
POC anglo-persian oil company go verify
it for your own self so you can see the
history of it on what took place so
Ron's like okay let's do it
but then Britain said we'll take 84% you
keep 16% why because we know how to do
this but you keep 16% will keep 84% that
first Iran was kind of not even like
okay let's do it we kind of need your
help anyways and we'll protect you it's
almost like the Mafia in New York you
have a business you give us such and
such and you keep this but we'll protect
you will give you protection okay we'll
do it
and then Iran started getting stronger
not wait a minute why are we giving this
to you we don't want to do that at
Mossad every negotiation then next thing
you know us
UK teamed up together and we have to
create a coupe and we have to create a
fall and then there was a fall and then
shock came and shall we negotiated a
deal and to control and they're like oh
wait a minute now we lost control
so this is our oil this is our land what
do you mean with it this is our country
this is not your oil we own this oil so
I understand the fear of Venezuelans
when they see you and us and Mike Pence
getting involved because I what are we
gonna do here but there's also to the
opposite side there's also community I
was speaking out of event a couple weeks
and I talked about what's taking place
in Venezuela a bunch of NSO ins came to
me afterwards the opposite side is the
following that a lot of Venezuelans when
they can't feed their family when they
don't have medicine they're willing to
do anything at that moment to get back
into survival mode so I wouldn't hundred
percent say no to it and I wouldn't
hundred percent say yes to it maybe
create an arrangement because I dunno a
lot of eyeballs are gonna be on how sexy
Venezuela still is because the oil is
still there the structure needs to
change and in order for the structure to
change its going to be a little bit ugly
it's gonna be pretty bad it's gonna be
at the hands of many people dying
unfortunately this is just kind of what
happens with oil money power and
socialism
it's just what takes place but this
ought to be something for a lot of us
and this leads me point number 10 which
is who's next who's next with this who
can this happen to next I know a lot of
us are looking at it from outside oh my
gosh I feel so bad for people in
Venezuela oh my gosh I feel so bad for
them look what they're going through
look what they're going through do you
remember I open up the video that a lot
of time we look at somebody else going
through divorce cancer crisis issues
business going we look at other people
who are not us because we're amazing
it'll never happen to me it'll never
happen to my country it can happen to
any Empire so one thing the moment you
forget that incentives create hard work
create effort create movement create
everybody paying the price and paying
their own bills that's what a country
can be relying on for a long time
because it's the right values and
principles but if you rely on something
for free something to give away
something you don't have to work for
something that's just going to be given
away to you and all the people that are
creating the jobs are becoming too rich
take the land away take that business
away and they're kind of sitting there
saying we'll listen if I don't
incentives I want to go to another
country because entrepreneurs and people
who are driven by incentives no one
wants to leave their homeland I'm from
Iran believe me no one wants to leave
their homeland but they will gladly
leave their homeland if you put him in a
position where they cannot give their
kids their blood the life they want to
give like this they will disappear
because everybody thinks family first
and if a country thinks that way they
keep talent if they don't think that way
there's a reason why you lose nearly
five million people that left your
country to other places whether that
number is two million or five million
then as well as the size of Texas that
31 million people even living there two
millions high five Millions high and
they're leaving and it's the
hard-working people leaving not the
people that are relying on the programs
it's the people that still know how to
work so as you're watching is your
sincere someone cares so Pat I got this
this is amazing what's taking place what
can I do next a few things one I want
you to watch the video the DNA of an
entrepreneur this is a speech I gave
when I lived in an RV and I went from LA
to Miami to Toronto to San Fran back to
LA 30 days I spoke to a few thousand
people about the concept of the DNA of
an entrepreneur right go watch that
video the link will be over here the DNA
of an entrepreneur the other one if
you're Venezuelan you want to know the
history of what happened with Iran with
the whole oil read the book or listen to
the audio all the Shahs men by Stephen
Kinzer
that'll Teta history of what happened
with Iran's oil crisis and if you want
today's PDF of the notes I talked about
text us at seven four seven two six zero
eight four six one once again seven four
seven two six zero eight four six one we
will send you the PDF of today's message
about the ten things we all can learn
from Venezuela if you got any questions
comments comment below and if you
haven't subscribed to the channel click
on the sub button thanks so much for
watching take everybody bye-bye